saturday I would love it if you were my
date I can't do that because like you
and I ever see each other again this
film was awesome because it's not only
hilarious but it breaks female
stereotypes flip-flopping the classic
romantic comedy mold of bad boy meets
good girl yeah what is already to make
this uh thank you first of all I I live
in New York I feel pretty fortunate that
I don't have a lot of dealings with
Hollywood Vanessa and I are safely
nestled in New York um and I know it
seems like and I think you're right that
we typically see the generals the other
way but that wasn't a conscious decision
and this has just really been my
experience and the ones of all the women
are close to actually and I was falling
in love when I wrote it it was very true
for me what was going on with me at the
time and Judd really encouraged me to
write a really personal script Judds
films do always feel very improvised
like how how much freedom does he give
you guys to go off script he likes it
when you go off script he likes to he
likes the dialogue to feel very real but
amy was really good at it too a couple
of takes we were screaming at each other
and it was really I wasn't feeling good
about it it just felt kind of forest and
weird and Amy pulled a really good dreck
she said I'm gonna just let's just do
one that's real calm like let's just do
a calm one and I was like all right so
we started one that was very calm and
then she jumped my line and started
yelling at me and I got really defensive
yeah because in my head I was like any
what are you doing you just ruined the
same so I got man and that's the take we
used I'd like to Lena you're clever but
you're not too brainy you're Prettyish
and you're not gorgeous you're
approachable thank you yeah you and Amy
work at snuff mm yeah yeah what do you
wish events magazine would write about I
mean I know I mean I don't read them so
like kind of
you can't but I can Eunice's I'm I told
you this will end up coming up and raise
awareness he's calling me how's that
he'd call you guys just a sec this is
Amy I think you butt-dialed me no I
dialed you with my fingers she say
between my face hang up he's obviously
like sick or something I was calling us
they had a really good time last night i
was wonder if you want it to I'm gonna
call the police